[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're picking up a conversation
that we've gone back to just kind of
like looking at different phases of our
lives and friendship different phases
kind of focusing in on the different
versions of ourselves different versions
of ourselves
um and this one is the post College like
right out of college
college graduates fresh college graduate
version which if you listen to ear
biscuits we've covered different aspects
they are listening to it uh if you've
listened to multiple episodes especially
as we've talked about different things
that happen in our lives at that point
we're going to be making at least I am I
don't know what you're going to be doing
I'm making an effort to talk about
things that I feel like I haven't talked
about before from that time period in
different aspects of it just so it's not
like oh yeah we talked about being
graduates when we were like in Crusade
and like the whole missionary thing like
we've taught about that we're not going
to talk about that
yeah I'll try I'll try to make an effort
okay make an effort make an effort I'll
make an effort
um yeah I think when you focus in on
that window of time that version of us
it's it's totally different I was a
totally different person and I am
interested in how that
reflected on our friendship like we're
two totally different people than we are
now yet we were still best friends so
you know it's
it's something I'm grateful for but
today is something that I'm curious
about
uh I did want to tell you I never told
you about my rolling loud experience
well I found out about it through the
internet if it
so I I mean in general terms what did
you've got a viral link
on the internet rolling loud is a is a
the world's largest hip-hop Festival
I don't know I think that's probably
what they call it and there's
um it's in multiple places around the
world and it happened around Lincoln's
birthday and like six or nine months in
advance he was asking me about it and we
had started going to some hip-hop shows
together
and so I was like I'll buy you a ticket
if you don't mind if I buy myself a
ticket too
so Dad can tag along
yeah that alone and we we didn't talk
about the specifics of what that meant
like I never use the term tag along but
I did say
um when it got closer and he was like I
have some friends that are going I'm
like okay yeah I can
I can take you guys and then I realized
this is a three-day this is not just a
concert it's probably
might have been 100 performers across
three days it's a freaking I never been
to a music festival so I was a little
excited until I got close and then I I
had some trepidation about it but I said
I don't think I'm gonna go Friday but
I'm gonna go Saturday I'm gonna go
Sunday and then it went from I'm not
gonna go
Sunday at the same time as you but I am
going to bring you home Saturday and
Sunday
so that was my role was just bringing
them back home but beyond that they I'm
curious what what have you gathered
before I tell you firsthand my
experience I didn't know you'd seen the
anything online I'd seen a couple of
things well I knew you were going
um and I am
both from your previous experience but
also from Locke's experience of going to
a few like hip-hop
concerts and festivals
and seeing footage from them I know the
vibe yeah you know what I mean I know
the vibe and it's not the vibe that I
typically that I experienced let's say
at the Palomino Country Music Festival
which is really my vibe
and uh
I definitely didn't fit in and so I mean
it was a younger demo than this 44 year
old but I also know that you while
you're really into hip-hop you're also
kind of you're also not only you're a
middle-aged man but you're like a
particular middle-aged man you're on the
particular side of the spectrum of
military I'm particular which means
things like
I think I'd rather be sitting down
watching this you know what I'm saying
there's like they're that that's how I
feel about things right like when we
went to that John Mayer concert
and there was that what one row of
people in front of me and the girls were
standing up dancing I was like oh really
okay I just want to sit and watch John
Mayer that's what I'm here to do I'm
here to sit and watch John Mayer okay
yeah so I know that you have a little
bit of that message there were no seats
anywhere at this Festival like literally
I didn't see a chair anywhere right like
even the porta johns you had to hover
yeah and so when I saw the footage the
footage that is circulating uh it made
me laugh a lot it did
well I'll play it for you and give some
more context do I think the one clip
you're talking about but yeah um let's
see is that uh little Uzi vert you got
Travis Scott you've got future uh you
got Lil Wayne
headlining all of those people headline
at different points you got three stages
it was a it was a round Sofi Stadium it
was all Outdoors
in Inglewood
and
I get like Lincoln told me about Friday
night because we were we were filming on
Friday of and I was like I'm just too
tired to go to this I don't think I can
make it three days and I was starting to
get scared that this wasn't for me that
I needed to back out but the ticket
price like I didn't go through anything
I just bought a ticket
you know I didn't try to like use any
sort of Internet Fame and then just get
frustrated that it didn't work I just
bought Lincoln a ticket for his birthday
and just bought me a a three-day pass
he said he was texting me that first
night he was like
I was like how's it going he's like it's
going great it got scary a little bit
but I'm having a lot of fun
and he was talking about like the crowds
just kind of pushing in on the stage and
getting really cramped I don't like that
man he it was his first experience like
being in it wasn't just a mosh pit the
whole thing
there could be a mosh pit at any point
anywhere because it was all that type of
um
non-seeding Festival run rush the stage
kind of a thing it's just like being
pressed against other people and getting
this feeling and listen this is a six
seven person the few times that I've
been in that situation
and I'm like if one person falls We All
Fall like that I I start having this
claustrophobic reaction and there's you
know I'm looking on Twitter and there's
people talking about how somebody two
people died
and then like first of all that was not
true it's just people just start these
rumors because they just want to get
something going on the internet like a a
Twitter frenzy yeah
um but of course you know it's
um tragedies have happened not not the
least of which is uh people being
crushed I mean since rolling loud there
was uh there was a concert somewhere
else and two people did die
as a result of being crushed because
there was some sort of a scare and
people started running yeah so
it happens there's that's the skit that
is the scary part of it
um but when I when I showed up on
Saturday with Lincoln and his four
friends
um they had already gotten the lay of
land the day before and then they were
just walking up to the main stage and I
walked up there with them and you know
towards the stage at least and this was
you know four o'clock in the afternoon
broad daylight things weren't really
turnt yet
and it's cold in L.A right now I was
chilly city girls were um playing I do
not have an opinion about this just a
general reference to the fact that there
were some girls from the city you're
saying No this is a group okay this is a
group got it and so I turned a link and
I was like listen I'll meet up with you
I'm gonna go get the lay of the land I
haven't seen everything there's lots of
like booths and stuff like this I'm just
gonna walk around and see the stuff
you've already seen
and I'm gonna you know and I was
thinking I'm gonna give you space to be
with your friends I don't think we
didn't again we didn't talk about it and
he was fine with anything he's very good
with the flow and his friends are really
cool really nice but like I was like I
need to give them some space I don't
want to be just like hovering around
like with Dad energy so instead I went
walking around with strange middle-aged
man unless you recognize him and then
it's that guy from the Internet by
himself by himself
um I'm proud of you I would not have
done that I I really like that I was
like really curious to see if I'll be
recognized at all I didn't wear a hat
um
that first day
and I was like I bet you
I bet you I'll blow a few people's minds
oh oh that's okay and I mean and that's
what happened like I really started to
get a kick out of the fact I'd just be
walking and then somebody
and you know there are some people in
the 30s mostly in their 20s and they're
like just Jaws are dropping people start
coming up to me not getting mobbed or
anything but
um I went to this one booth where
they're selling cereal
bowls of cereal for five dollars that's
actually pretty affordable yeah yeah for
La food and I was like this is my spot
and people were like
blink
or sometimes they'd be like red yeah and
um
the big the big question I was getting
was
why are you here
I find that such an interesting one
right here I find it interesting that
people are surprised and my answer was
always why are you here
I mean it's amazing implying I'm it's
the same reason but I mean that's the
first thing people thought is like I
didn't think you would be here it's not
like it's common knowledge across the
board with any casual person who
recognizes my face from a thumbnail that
I like hip-hop music right but hip-hop
is like the most popular form of Music
in the on the planet that's true and
this is lost but going to Rolling loud
is not it's it's a little bit more
unless you're right in that expected
demo it's more about
um the you gotta overcome some hurdles
to be at this thing you know so social
hurdles it's like I'm willing to be
you got there's it's another level it is
another level of commitment I think that
was implied so I didn't take offense of
people saying why you're not here I just
got a kick out of people just being
just
trying to make sense of it and I thought
you know if some pictures make their way
on Twitter
it might surprise up your Cloud it might
surprise some more people
I didn't really think of it in terms of
clout I just thought of in terms of
light that'll be fun to see what
discussions can be had here in real time
and maybe on Twitter later so I wasn't
embarrassed to be walking around alone I
did have a cover story which I started
to use I'm lost where am I uh yeah I'm
looking I'm looking for
um The Home Depot yeah I've got to do
some Home Improvement for my family
um installing a toilet
um
my cover story was
my son is also here with some of his
friends but then it just seemed like I'm
the distant chaperone and that ain't
true either because I really wanted to
be there my son is somewhere somewhere
here but I felt the need sometimes to
say why I was alone it was like my son's
here too with his friends but and they
were like who you here to see and I'm
like Lil yachty
like love his new album big fan of Lil
yachty not I don't have to be a fan of
all of his music to be a fan of his
approach to everything he does like I'm
uh
artistically I like his artistic
approach he takes risks and I was like I
hope he takes a risk at his show on
Sunday
um
and so I'm just walking around enjoying
people's reactions and then
it occurred to me as I was walking back
to see Don Toliver I like Don Toliver
um
I knew that Lincoln and his friends were
going to be up there but there was no
cell phone service once you got to the
main stage you had to like back up
something about the location or all
these people there so I'm walking up
trying to find him and I'm realizing the
crowd has gotten really thick a lot
further back for Don Toliver than it did
for city girls okay I'm not going to be
able to get to Lincoln I cannot
communicate with anyone on the group
that that we created because they're all
down there and no service so now I'm
just alone at a concert I'm not just I'm
not perusing booths I'm in a crowd of
people that then
there's people standing kind of looking
over heads there's some space you can
kind of walk through people walk through
people and then you get a little bit
closer and it starts to get dense
and so I wasn't I wasn't anywhere near
the front by any means but I would I got
to the middle
and was waiting for him to come out
oh there's no one he's not even playing
yet not even playing yet and uh
I'm smushed with people as he comes out
and then
the energy just starts pushing people
forward and back and like
then they had to stop the show a few
times and just get back like trying to
give people in the front who were being
smushed too much and I knew Lincoln was
up there uh just get back just everybody
take a step back and I'm like that
nobody does nobody does that you got to
have some sort of you got to develop a
system I'm thinking like do I need to
get up there and get a mic and like help
walking through if you're in the very
back and if you don't move no one in
front of you is going to be able to move
so we got to start at the very back
that's not a very rolling loud
announcement I don't think yeah the guy
got up there and he was like all right
everybody on the left take a step to
your left
and then nobody obviously your left or
our left yeah right everybody on the
right take a step you're right and then
he was like nobody moving he's like
everybody
on this side if you can see me
step to the way that I'm pointing that
was better
and then it was like and if you're in
the back you gotta move back it's like
it actually started to work and then
then the show resumed but like there was
a lot of pushing a lot of being in
personal space and I'm like okay my
hands are up by my chin
and I ca I couldn't put them down in my
pockets if I wanted to
and this is fun
it was fun because in the midst of it
like people were looking at me and they
were like and some people would
recognize me but but now we're a family
we're stuck together in a group right
and so I quickly learned if anybody
recognizes me I'm just gonna turn the
conversation to the music like if we're
waiting during the show nobody's talking
everybody's just like jamming out or
whatever
so I was like
I liked this there was an anonymity to
it yes I got recognized a few times but
like once you settle in the spot and
like people are playing like the show
starts it's kind of like you get lost in
a sea of people and it was
it was it was fun he brought out Justin
Bieber
wow for a song
um that was cool
uh Lil yachty was the second night
that's I was more interested in him so
Travis Scott was okay
but like the next day I showed up later
and Lincoln was like we've made our way
to the front of the main stage
so
let's just work out when we're going to
meet up when we leave I'm like okay
that's great he was like
I know you want to see yachty he's on
the other stage get some good footage
for me because I'm gonna I have to give
up seeing Lil yachty to stay at the
front of the stage he he and his friends
end up staying there for like
almost 10 hours
they were like giving water bottles in
the front and people passing water but
what do you do about Mick Trading uh he
will hold it or you just do something a
little bit indecent
you squat right there or something if
it's an emergency there's where you need
that Stadium pal I know Stadium pal
because all the kids are wearing the Big
Jeans now yeah you could probably fit
four or five Stadium Pals in your pants
people you can bring it's highly
regulated you can't you have to bring in
a clear little bag you can't bring in
supplies but you can bring in a water uh
balloon thing like the thing that I have
when I go like a Camelback a Camelback
when I go mountain biking you can bring
one of those in I knew I wasn't going to
see him or his friends until the very
end after future performed and I was
like
all right I'm gonna watch a little bit
of I miss money bag yo
heard he wasn't great anyway a lot of
these people they use these backing
tracks and they're like the backing
tracks doing all the heavy lifting
but if you're a pro and a legend like
Lil Wayne you bring out a live band and
you have very minimal backing track
because you are the goat and you bring
out Nicki Minaj wow I didn't see the
yachty have a band uh I'll get to that
so I was waiting for Yadi and I so Lil
Uzi vert's supposed to be this like
Dynamic performer
um
so I was like I'm gonna watch half of
his set before I leave to like get ready
to get up close for Yadi and the dude
comes out there and he's nuts but like
the thing that's the middle screen he's
playing
uh
clips from horror movie B movies like
the most grotesque moments from horror
movies like blood guts nastiness right
okay the entire time the entire not one
song
the entire time right not time really
timed out to anything uh no and I had to
after the second song I was like you
know what I I have to leave I have to
leave because this is stomach turning
that's why I did it to get rid of people
like you yeah Lincoln said he felt a
little nauseous yeah well he's a Neil
but he was up at the front he couldn't
do anything about it
uh I think I would have liked this
um had a friend with him who the first
night
get just got smushed so much that they
pulled him over the rail and then he was
like oh my shoe my shoe and then the
security guards like your shoe and
he pulls him out and then escorts him
out of the out of the area that's what I
would have said and so when I found him
later he'd been walking around the
entire show that was at like five
o'clock at night
on uh Saturday he walked around the
entire festival with one shoe and one
sock
I mean your shoe man yes
so I I'm down with that too I got to the
front I might go next year row of uh Lil
yachty what because I was there like 45
minutes in advance and like people well
I got the front row of the normal people
and then there's a VIP section
so I was as close as I could be without
being very important being normal yeah
and I'm getting to know I was like I
started talking to the people around me
and I'm like
hey I just want to talk to you because I
think we might be smooshed up against
each other a little bit and I just want
to be friends first and there were a
couple other people who were there like
alone and they were just there to see
Yadi and some people didn't were just
there because it was close and but I'm
you know it was it was fun to like talk
about the music and uh people think they
knew who I was but then they didn't and
it was just like ah you know I think
don't worry about it we're just here to
have fun and then this guy showed up
right as the show started with a
freaking VHS camera oh and that's what
shot this video he he was like he
recognized me and he was like filming
the Lil yachty show yes he did have a
full band yes he did play Let's Start
here he like played the first three
songs of that album which is like super
psychedelic like him channeling Pink
Floyd people didn't know what to do with
it that's a new one that's a new one and
so he made a bold choice of like opening
his show with that and it was like I was
I was loving it
and yeah this guy with a VHS camcorder
like beast on his shoulder
was filming me so
welcome to MTV News
[Music]
and I'm having a fabulous time
smoke I don't really fit in do it that's
the part I saw I didn't see the MTV News
for it
see there's yachty
I've met Yadi before he was at the at
the gate the game awards game awards I'd
like to meet him again I want him to
come on our show or just be my friend so
I'm assuming that you uh weren't
officially there with MTV News that was
a joke yeah and it wasn't 2013 either
which is what I said in a moment I just
thought if these guys you're bad with
numbers if this guy's pointing a camera
at me
I'm gonna act like I know I don't fit in
it's like what what would be the reason
I would be here 2013. because I didn't
even hear that the first time because I
am I'm a I'm a correspondent for MTV
that's the only logical reason and I
love the fact that the title of the
video is rolling loud 2013. like he
totally wins shout out to Jojo World dot
International on Instagram who posted
this video
um
yeah he didn't know I was gonna say that
stuff I didn't even know if he was
rolling audio I'm glad he was but like
yeah and then I think I said 2013
because
MTV doesn't have vj's in 2023 and I was
trying to finish it was intentional I
was trying to come up with a date in the
past that felt like it could still be
realistic maybe twenty twenty two
thousand three thousand three is what I
should have said
um but yeah you can I mean see my hands
are up by my chin
and then I'm you I'm just smushed in
with all these you look uh
simultaneously
like you're having a good time but
there's also a sense of fear
I was a little
I mean they at a certain point the
artist including Yadi would like they
would in between songs they would like
yell like open it up
open it up
and they're trying to create a a mosh
Zone
where it's like you open up a hole Yeah
and then When the Beat Drops everybody
just kind of slams in there yeah
so people can kind of mosh I don't care
for that I mean I understand that some
people I was close enough to the rail
that when he would start yelling open it
up I would just get pushed against the
rail
there was a huge guy who I turned around
one time and some they had opened up for
him and he was just flat on his face
just
passed out
they had two security guards came in
just like whoa took three people to
hoist this guy up he was so big he
fainted he did yeah or if he took a nap
I don't know what he did one of the
other but I mean uh I had I had a blast
I enjoyed I enjoyed just being in a sea
of humanity listening to some just
vibing out to some music so you'll be
back I think I'll do it again and I
think I would do it alone
okay well I was basically that's
basically what I did
you probably could get some people to go
with you I mean I'm not going but I mean
I do think you could get some people to
go with you I'm I was surprised that I
enjoyed being alone in a sea of people I
don't know something about it was
it was fun
it I mean like the Swain from anonymity
to being recognized I don't know it was
just it was a strange experience I'm
glad I had it
airbuscus is supported by chime some of
the hardest goals to set have to be
Financial ones but they don't have to
feel so out of reach with chime secured
credit Builder Visa credit card you can
start building credit with your own
money through on-time payments and small
everyday purchases like groceries
streaming and gas members see an
increase of 30 points to their credit
scores on average chime reports your
payments to the major credit bureaus to
help you build credit over time all with
no annual fees no large security
deposits and no credit checks to apply
start making your financial dreams a
reality with chime signing up only takes
two minutes and it doesn't affect your
credit score get started at chime.com
ear thus chime.com ear to chime credit
Builder Visa credit card is issued by
stride Bank NA pursuant to a license
from Visa USA chime checking account and
200 qualifying direct deposit required
to apply for the secured chime credit
Builder Visa credit card based on a
study conducted by Experian credit
Builder members observed an average
30-point FICO score 8 increase after
eight months with regular on-time
payments results May Vary seechime.com
for details out of network ATM
withdrawal fees May apply except at
money pass ATMs in a 7-Eleven or any
Allpoint or VISA plus Alliance ATM
in over three years since uh
our Saturday show let's talk about that
started remember that or actually when
it came to an end Stevie hosted hosted
by Stevie and everybody's been asking
for it they want it back and we said you
know what we'll bring it back sorta
we'll bring it back for a special as a
special on the mythical Society uh we've
actually shot that and had an incredible
time doing it there's a lot there's a
lot to enjoy yeah yeah I think we all
lived our best lives yes in the context
of that uh there was I was surprised
surprised a literal surprise for link
there's a musical performance a couple
actually there were some embarrassing
things that Stevie asked about on
Twitter that she covered in
gross detail
so this is available for first second
and third degree on the mythical Society
so all you got to do is be a paying
member of any degree of mythical
society.com and you can get access to
this it is premiering today March 29th
mythicalsociety.com let's talk about
that so set the stage we graduated from
college
you graduated in
technically 2001 but
um I co-opt and was still working at IBM
so I was kind of
right right right and not because
Christy graduated in 2000. I graduated
in December 2000 along with you Co-op
but
you were already
married and I was not married when I
graduated
so this was when I was living over there
at Driftwood Manor
right and I had uh with the with the
help of my in-laws
put a down payment on
a really not great apartment if you
remember this place
um yeah the full purchase price for a
three bedroom two bath apartment
uh was eighty one thousand dollars in
2000 to the year 2002
2000 yeah and um so what I was doing
because I was still a college student
and I was paying this payment to what I
did
is uh I started inviting a lot of people
to live with me beyond what code should
allow I think at one point I had five
other guys living with me I was sleeping
on the floor what and I was charging
them all
rent to cover the rent and I covered I
more than covered the rent oh nice
because I had because the I remember
sleeping on the floor I remember my
payment my mortgage was 623 a month
and uh then there was like some taxes
and insurance that maybe sent it up you
know still under 700 a month
and I had five guys in there each paying
200 a month to live there oh so I was
Cash flowing right from the start and
none of these people one of those
YouTube Finance Bros were people that we
knew because no Greg was one of them I
slept on the floor in Greg's room
oh really
yeah but there was a there was a I mean
it was it was a rotating batch of people
who were just willing to live with me
and willing to pay
this is like a halfway house
no one was in recovery
uh it was just a bunch of crusade guys
okay you know there and I mean there was
a bunch of people that look Jesse's
cousin lived there for a while I never
went there uh well you should have I
probably went there I probably visited
you there once because I was a newlywed
Christy had graduated uh we had got
married
uh immediately and then we both started
I I was still yeah I was still studying
and working at IBM and she started a
teaching job what you you had your
engineering job right I was working at
black and Beach well so upon graduation
I had oh I had done a summer internship
I think with black and Beach and then I
was Yeah so basically in January of 2001
and that's a firm that does what uh
designs power plants so like natural gas
power plants mostly is what we're doing
at the time and I was in the civil
engineering department and I was
basically uh coordinating like
underground utilities whatever
and but I was engaged
oh is your dog okay
um
I was engaged at the time to get married
in June 2001 so I was going to get
married in six months and
this is a weird thing because this is
this moment in time where I was
like this very involved
uh landlord essentially doing all these
repairs because the other thing that
happened is Jesse's dad
had bought that house in Chapel Hill
that duplex in Chapel Hill
because you know he's like a rental
property guy that's one of the reasons I
bought that apartment is because he was
like this is what you do man you gotta
you know he's like real estate guy so
and he knew I was marrying his daughter
and so he was like trying to get some
things in place and I'm grateful that he
did including
they Jesse and her friends were living
in this duplex that he had bought for
her like her sophomore year or something
and he was like I'm going to I'll sell
this to you for what I bought it oh
and so and this would be and that was
going to be the house that we lived in I
wasn't going to live in the the college
apartment with just yet we were going to
live in a like a slightly nicer place
but the way we were going to pay for it
was by renting out the bottom
to another to another family or a couple
or whatever because it was two bedrooms
kind of it was a duplex two bedrooms for
us two bedrooms for them and
I say all this because I've had for I
was thinking about this on the way in
how much of my life was consumed with
doing repairs on things so I was an
engineer that sucks and I remember this
other engineer named Lyle something
and
I don't know if you remember that
downstairs
in Chapel Hill but it was it was a
basement and it was a weird space that
was like a completed basement but it was
cinder block walls that had been painted
and I was like if we're gonna rent this
thing out and actually get some money or
actually get somebody to care to live
here yeah I need to turn it into a good
space so I'm going to put sheetrock
over the cinder block walls now I got to
figure out how to do that now step one
was the Bible study that I was leading
in NC State those good a bunch of good
old boys who were like really good at
stuff I got them to come over and like
do like the furring strips to like
create a base for it oh wow and then I
ended up maybe with the help of like one
of them ended up
uh you know what I have no idea probably
or I probably said it was Fellowship
either way they had a great time no it's
fellowship and
I remember
this is before I mean this is 2001 and
yes the internet existed but it was
YouTube didn't exist and you couldn't
figure out how to do things by going on
the internet
interesting so I was like I've got to
put this sheetrock up and then I've got
to mud and sand mud and like sand and
finish the sheetrock and this became my
existence because what I would do so go
to work
and at lunch I would go over to Lyle's
Cube
I can't remember that's his name sorry
Lyle
and he was and I would be and I was like
I'm doing he had done sheetrock in his
house himself and so I would tell him at
what stage I was in and he would like
tell me what to do next
then I would go home
uh actually I wouldn't go home I would
go to Jesse where Jesse lived because I
was living in this apartment in Raleigh
yeah I would go out to Chapel Hill after
work and I would get in the basement and
I would work
and listen to music for some reason a
lot of Natalie Merchant don't know I
don't know how I went through this I
went through this Natalie Merchant phase
so I'm lit and then like Sarah
Mclaughlin all these like uh Moody women
there's something about Moody women and
she rock that really does something for
me
and I would just spend all this time
getting this that's a that's a calendar
by the way getting you know 2024
calendar pre-order now Moody women and
sheetrock are they and are they are they
putting sheetrock up because I tell you
you sweat you will sweat with some
Sheetrock I could look at some Moody
women doing some Sheetrock they're not
happy about it
um usually sometimes they get happy but
most times they're unhappy about it but
it's just a weird moment in time and
then I think January they're happy but
every other month there and then I was
like installing toilets like
single-handedly doing Plumbing
they do a PVC pipe I had to figure I had
to put this like pump sump pump in this
thing like this explains why I think our
friendship just came to a creature
screeching halt it didn't come to a
screech Hall it didn't but um I mean as
in I was very well you were a landlord
engaged I was trying to I'll tell you
what I was doing in a minute but like
yeah it was like
you know we were in this transitional
period so it was like
there wasn't
we were building our futures yeah I was
like very committed to like I'm gonna
have this this apartment in Raleigh that
I'm gonna go and do all the repairs
myself because that's how you make money
you can't hire anybody to do other
repairs I have to figure out how to do
all these like minor like minor repairs
you know sheetrock
Plumbing Etc did you figure it out or
did you yeah did it because that always
ends in catastrophe for me I actually
got pretty skilled I like I could
install
um I mean it's all normal stuff like I
could install like a sink
fully like pipe it in I could install
the toilet like literally like put the
ceiling just by talking to your cube
mate a lot of the stuff is like just
talking to the people at Home Depot and
then like reading directions there's not
a whole lot to it I made some mistakes I
learned some lessons uh I can lay tile
yeah clay tile obviously paint that kind
of thing
I hate doing that stuff now because I
did it so much in my 20s because I kept
those those properties and just kept
going and doing all the repairs on them
so by June when you got married
well then you moved into that duplex you
moved out of the other place obviously
yeah yeah and um you were still working
at black Veatch Jesse was uh he was a
student still when we got married
yeah so she's we won't say What year she
was
I've said it this many times she was
going into her junior year in college
when we got married okay don't recommend
it but if you come from an Evangelical
uh circle like I did in the early 2000s
you probably have a you probably relate
to this
um you get married so you can have sex
without guilt
and that's what we did it worked out for
us
because we did wait yeah we did so you
could have sex yeah right I love it I
wanted to spend the rest of my life with
her but I really wanted to have sex with
her as well right the only way to
complete that equation is get married
yeah
and meanwhile over here in my neck of
the woods which was Apex North Carolina
yeah I was
finishing up my
studies but mostly working at IBM as an
Industrial Engineer and they had like a
department like my department had
um probably I think it was like five or
six industrial Engineers that were then
assigned a different places different
things like there were there were all
these buildings like in at RTP the IBM
campus like had all these Office
Buildings but then also manufacturing
buildings and there was some that like
would build servers and then some that
would build desktops and laptops and
then there was one that would just
refurbish
all of the stuff that came in off lease
and it doesn't it didn't even have to be
IBM equipment but it was like
um plate pads they would refurbish
laptops think pads uh thinkpads with the
little servers little red nipple that
was the mouse yeah
that thing felt kind of felty on top but
grippy at the same time I kind of liked
it yeah
it's just like yeah it's just like
pushing on that on that Rudolph the
Red-nosed nipple are his nipples red too
I bet there they are like hello I think
they're covered in fur oh okay
um they're vestigial for him as a male
reindeer
could probably get some milk out of them
if you wanted to anyway
the place that I worked
um
the the facility I was in building 693.
had all the refurbishing stuff so each
they were all there were different
manufacturing lines that would refurbish
different things including monitors
and um so like and then there was like
this huge Warehouse with all the parts
in it and like I worked with uh shout
out to my friend Mark still friends with
Mark after all these years like he
started full time when I was still a
co-op back then
trudging through all of these warehouses
full of
just computer parts
and so my job was
designing I kind of worked under another
engineer because I was still a co-op but
the first big job I got was redesigning
The Packaging line for everything that
was refurbished within go through this
hole in the wall on a conveyor belt
and then it would get they would box it
up and tape it up and then put it on a
pallet and then put it put it in on
temporary storage then ship it out to
wherever it was going next
so
it's and then everybody who worked on
the other side of that wall the vast
majority of them were from uh they were
African guys they were like
mostly from Nigeria like I loved going
in there and talking to those guys they
were like the nicest guys they were
always happy to see me and literally
they know that my job was to try to
reduce the number of them that it took
to do what they did to find everything
you know find some efficiencies and uh
when I redesigned this line
I had to I said you know what
let's buy this machine that will
um
take a box
and it'll tape it up so you don't have
to tape it that doesn't become a manual
process you just you build the Box you
put the thing in it and then you push it
through this machine and it tapes the
bottom and the top at the same time and
spits it out real nice instead of having
to struggle to like tape this thing
so like my big project was finding that
machine talking to like these vendors to
like bring this thing in and sell me on
it and do any one of them or do we need
two of them and do we need to like
change the trajectory of these conveyor
belts an industrial engineer in general
doesn't design things they design how
things are made
so it's more about the process of making
something than it is what it the design
of actually the thing right so
I designed how it got in a box
and I remember showing up the weekend
that they had to like tear everything
down when like the line was down and
then rebuild it and like
I had I was so nervous like I probably
sweated so much like I had no confidence
at that stage of my life like I was felt
like such a fish out of water well being
in this place I mean
you probably shouldn't have had the
level of responsibility that you did I
learned a lot but I know that I
shouldn't have had the level of
responsibility that I had they throw
these Junior Engineers into like
I mean I had people like checking up on
me and looking over my shoulder right my
plan was approved but then when I had to
actually oversee the building of it like
people were coming to me and like hey
when you design this
um there was a three foot Gap but as you
can see there's no three foot Gap no one
can Ocean's not gonna let anybody walk
through here what are we gonna do and
I'm like oh I knew this is gonna
happen let me go let me go clean out my
britches
you know so uh we didn't actually
cut any jobs in that instance
um
more efficient let me ask you a question
I feel good about that so anyone no one
from Nigeria or anywhere lost their job
anyone watching this who uh is not
familiar with our story and knows us
from a good mythical morning and knows
your personality and the things that
make you funny Etc
um
is surprised right he's very surprised
like
right this was your job that like you
who I know as the guy who can't hold a
knife and you know has to have the rules
of the game explain to him multiple
times before he really gets him yeah uh
is making these decisions at IBM I've
definitely gotten stupider and so let's
just go out on let's just go ahead and
say that well what do you I don't think
I was just dumb then
I think that you oh like were you a
different did your brain work
differently back then like what do you I
mean how do you account for that the
perfectionism of like the thing that I
loved the most was like getting on
AutoCAD and reflecting a physical
environment completely accurately Within
an AutoCAD environment but would you
enjoy doing that right now if that was
what the afternoon entailed not uh
probably for maybe a couple of weeks
but not not for years
you know and again still I didn't do
everything right it's like oh this is
this three foot Gap doesn't exist in the
real world
or
this tape machine doesn't actually work
as good as you thought it did and now
we're mad at you
did it work now not so well uh it had
its issues it needed a person there to
make sure that it worked in person
that's how it usually goes uh
so
my job I was I wouldn't say my job was
stressful but I certainly made it
stressful
and so like that was it was this sense
of like okay I've entered the real world
I got I'm tucking in my shirt
for some you know everybody was and well
you had to you couldn't go you couldn't
not have a your shirt tucked in right
you might get caught in a conveyor belt
you would be told you have to tuck your
shirt in
oh no one would no one told me to tuck
my shirt I wore jeans but I did tuck my
shirt I wore jeans on Friday oh wow you
had to wear slacks
every day you can only wear jeans on
Friday
yeah because I was in an office
environment yeah I wasn't I bet you
that's not the case anymore it's
probably I mean I'm sure kova changed
everything but it probably oh yeah it
lasts 20 years have changed a lot
and then Christy had just started her uh
her job as a high school math teacher
and she did the same thing I did was she
like she probably could have been really
good at she was really good at it she
was nominated for like freshman teacher
of the year like first year teacher of
the year I think she got that award but
she she stressed herself out so much in
the process that like we you know we
were both in this place where it's like
all right we got it we got to do this
life thing right and so I remember being
and then we were newlyweds and we were
house sitting for a couple that was
missionaries in Slovakia and taking care
of a full-grown well I'm a Weimaraner
named Solomon
I remember Solomon uh beautiful dog
um Regal very Regal Beagle yep and he
stayed in the house and he was he was
lovely
but yeah it was like all of a sudden we
were thrust into the real world here you
are like installing toilets and
sheetrock and I'm and I'm doing tape
machines and trying to support my new
wife in her
um geometry
excursions you know it's good to have a
woman who knows her way around a
triangle she's only three years older
than I would say four or five she's only
like six years older than the students
she was teaching I know area right you
know yeah has like a first year we were
all kids of high school students very
much kids now one of the things that
we'll get into talking about how what we
do today was manifesting itself in those
days and how that happened
uh and maybe talk about it in a way that
we haven't talked about it before but
one of the things that was happening
with me
always been a relatively confident
person uh and haven't had much you know
I'm kind of I'm kind of an introvert
right and I don't like drawing attention
to myself a lot of times but when the
attention comes I can usually settle
into like comfortably commanding it you
know what I mean yeah uh in front of a
group of people doing a presentation
talking talking about something
uh but one of the things that happened
to me and this is how it's not like this
never happens it happens very
infrequently now but it happened
frequently then I want to see if you
relate to this because what you're
saying about like the in your pants
moment yeah made me think of it
so there was an engineer uh who was a
senior engineer who Jeremy was his name
and he was basically the guy that he
wasn't my boss he was a co-worker but he
was the guy that I went to to help me do
everything okay I'm gonna ask him so
many questions so many questions about
so many different steps that I got to
and he was not particularly
um he didn't have the best attitude in
terms of wanting to help me
he he didn't he would not take the
moniker of mentor
he seems that he was a reluctant advisor
but one of the things that would happen
and it didn't just happen with him I
would go to somebody's cubicle and I
would be asking a question or trying to
explain something and I would have this
moment of embarrassment
yeah right a moment of embarrassment
that would turn into a little bit of a
red face
because it doesn't happen very often
anymore
like and then I would know that my face
was red
and then I would get embarrassed about
that oh here comes this this Loop and
I'm like standing there asking this you
gotta run away question about this thing
and I'm like he knows I'm
embarrassed about something right now
and why am I embarrassed about this
thing right because it's a dumb question
and that happened I that had not
happened to me at all up until that
point in my life in college I kind of
understood what was going on and I found
my place and like I was like college
being in College move forward like I
know how I know how to present you're
the college guy here and to like assert
myself in this way like it was a great
environment for me
new job in having to like ask a lot of
questions and be doing some stuff that I
felt like I was in over my head
I started noticing that that was
happening and then I was like what is
wrong with me do I have an anxiety I
didn't understand I didn't know what
anxiety or anxiety disorder was at the
time and I'm not saying I didn't even
have one but like that started happening
you had an anxious phenomenon and it
only ever happened on a regular basis
during my engineering job that happened
to me in high school I remember really
there was this there were there were two
girls two friends of ours
in high school that like one time I was
talking to a I mean it was she was just
a friend and I remember I was talking to
her and I don't know what it was that I
was embarrassed about but like my face
started turning red and she was like why
is your face turning red and that oh
gosh you know when people pointing it
when you're talking to somebody and
they're like back from that why is your
face turning around why is your neck oh
turning around oh it makes me feel
uncomfortable I I know and it's like and
that makes it so much worse and then all
of a sudden it's like it's like it's
like a you're you're set a blaze
and there were two girls who would do it
um to me
and I got to the point and I they were
my friends so I had to talk to him all
the time but it got to a point where I
couldn't talk to them without getting
embarrassed for no reason except except
thinking that I was gonna get
embarrassed I got embarrassed because I
knew I was gonna I thought I was getting
embarrassed and it was two of them and
they were both they knew it too and they
had power over me I'd be like why is she
why is your face turning red
it's like can we just can you just
either I'm never going to talk to you
again or you're never going to ask me
that again yeah and then
it's if you ask somebody listen I mean
it would happen
after that oh my gosh just like
that High School experience would then
happen at other points in my life
um
and it would just kind of bring out that
trauma back like I don't want to over
sensationalize it but it was just like
it's a bad feeling isn't it when you're
like the words
what files should I pull up oh gosh I'm
getting so hot right now
what what is the worst man I think I've
gotten to a place where it's it's very
unlikely to happen interpersonally at
this point almost impossible but when it
but in a certain sized group
it could happen it could still happen
and then when it starts and it's almost
there's like a little bit of a fear of
it happening oh because it's obvious oh
you can definitely get in your head
about it so yeah I mean people think
that like
I I like if I ask trim or my my friend
from
back then like I think he would have
described my engineering uh approach as
like that I was still pretty fun I was
still there was still a lot of Link
happening but it wasn't like it does now
like I've given myself fully over over
the years of being a performer and you
know the LA influence like I when you
shed the expectations of having to tuck
your shirt in you can I you know just
yourself be as weird as you is something
that like is still an evolution for me
that the seeds of that were there then
and like the college version of me would
come out at work sometimes and but
mainly it was over lunch with co-worker
friends but also if I was given a
presentation I just couldn't help myself
but say something a little goofy like I
knew that everybody took everything
really seriously and there were so I had
these certain glints of
uh realization that none of this is
worth it but it was only like if if I
cracked a joke or I made my presentation
funny at the beginning I did that a few
times yeah other than that I took it
very seriously I remember having the
opportunity to do a presentation for
something in front of some Department
and like I prided myself on my college
presentations right that's how I made
A's in college which is like getting
snow them give me Charisma you do the
work but give me the presentation on the
day on the date it's gonna be fine
and
and I remember
just going into my my performance mode
which I had not done at all in any
context with anybody they were surprised
and people like came up after well that
was well I didn't know you had that in
you because I was like oh I guess I
haven't been that guy that guy whose
face turns red every time he talks to me
he sure nearly pulled one out he did a
great job with his presentation there's
jokes and funny slides yeah yeah yeah
um yeah but I never really had the
opportunity to fully
become myself there because what I was
doing wasn't really
it's not what you were hired for no but
I'm just saying it wasn't my that
environment for me I wasn't exercising
my full gifting no if you will but the
way that was happening so six months
into that
Jesse and I got married uh and so then
we're living in Chapel Hill but I'm
she's going to school I'm still
commuting to Black and Beach
you're married to Christy you're an apex
going like we're both sort of
establishing ourselves at like different
churches you know you're going to church
in Apex I'm going to church in Chapel
Hill which obviously as you know from
our backstory that's a really big part
of our lives so getting involved there
is like something that's kind of
unfolding right
but this is how the seed of what we do
now was still there and it was more of
like a sapling because it had been
planted early in our lives and in high
school and in college with all the weird
stuff that we did together videos that
we made
but because we had been asked to
MC Christmas conference and that was
something that was still happening
what we did is we said let's get
together
hell or high water let's get together
once a week at one of our homes and
we're going to just do creative things
we're going to we're going to write
songs we're going to conceptualize video
Concepts Etc all with this goal of
hey we've got a we've got to fill these
spots come December with these
entertaining ideas that we have
but boy I just if we had not had had
that right
that first of all that regular like we
had a goal we had something that we were
working towards but then we had this
we're gonna get together and that's how
we're going to incubate this creative
side of us
if we had not made that decision who
knows what we would be doing today and
where we would be yeah I think that I
mean we were we were we were hanging out
like we were making plans yeah as like
the four of us as couples I'm sure we
did stuff together I'm sure we did stuff
with Greg and his wife Jen and like
we were all hanging out and doing stuff
but it wasn't every weekend and we were
living in you know we're living 40
minutes apart and we also had no money
and we had no money so so yeah well
let's go out to eat it's like well hold
on our grocery budget is 200 right and
uh that's all for all the groceries for
the month and our eating out budget is
like a hundred dollars so I think we'll
go through that pretty fast I'm just
getting at the fact that I don't
I I think that if we hadn't had that
weekly Workshop
like on Thursday nights whenever it was
that I mean I I think our friendship
would have suffered at that point you
know we were working towards a common
goal of like we have this audience of
1300 college students at the end of the
year sure it's only February but let's
go ahead and we're so we took we were so
committed to it and um I I think that
that's
had to I mean it was a big con I don't
know if it was a Lifeline or a
friendship but it was certainly a big
contributor to us being
um staying close and and having this
thing to to work on together so it
wasn't just hey let's get together once
or twice a month whenever we we can get
our our weekend schedules to line up and
when we got together we not only worked
on like
conceptualizing skits a lot of it was
writing songs too I do remember that
because
um
I remember writing that a tribute to
friendship song
it's like that story song you wrote that
wasn't even funny for any reason I
remember getting together in the the
apartment before
the one that you moved into so I guess
we started it pretty early or maybe you
moved into that I don't remember going
to that the sandland Place apartment and
getting together I remember when I moved
out of 3000c there was a there was a few
months that we would still get together
there
and then I remember because there was a
semester in which we still all lived
there when you moved I'm sure you got
married and then when you got married
well not not just a few months not not
like that summer we lived there that
summer okay you got married in June we
continued to stay there for the summer
like leading up to the end of the
12-month lease
but then I I definitely remember driving
after working as an engineer like
getting on the road telling remember
Christy this is the night that I don't
come home because I leave work and I'm
going to Rhett's house and like Jesse
would like she was like
newlywed I'm Gonna Make You guys dinner
and want to be Rhett's friends coming
over and they're gonna work on their
stuff
well partly because they had told us to
keep
doing that you know right it's all
around the same time with Greg's wedding
where we wrote a song for his that's
right rehearsal dinner and they and
Jesse and Chrissy were like you guys
need to keep doing this because the
other thing that was happening it wasn't
just preparing for Christmas conference
but I don't remember what year it was
but
right around this time is when Cole
asked us to do the uh the show at
Carolina like the one night only thing
which we talked about this whole we're
kind of getting into this some that
stage that we talked about before but
that gave us something else to work
towards yeah
uh it was all in the like a
there wasn't there were not many years
in which
we ever thought I mean I kind of knew
going into engineering that it wasn't a
permanent thing for me because I tried
to like change the communications
because I thought I was just going to go
into Ministry
I was like I'm gonna go on stent or
something I'm going to be on staff a
crusade eventually but I gotta wait
until Jesse graduates so we can do that
so I I was a little bit more in love
with the stability of the job and it was
a good paint job
and at that point we weren't necessarily
thinking about doing it together like
there was no path to because what you
did is you full-time you went on stem
entertainment are you like you got a job
at like a campus but it wasn't until
Cole asked us to do that show Shane Dyke
saw us do that show it's like you guys
should do something as a position yada
yada all that stuff led to so we were
also working on that but so we were
pretty diligent like getting together
every week working on stuff
um developing developing our craft as
crappy as it was but we weren't the the
some funny observations I make now
we were not uh like performing for
anybody there was no Outlet it was like
no go to somebody's house and write some
songs knowing that we will perform these
for a bunch of college students at some
point but it wasn't like hey what if we
went to a comedy club like we never
thought to this day have never performed
at a comedy club right never I've never
done any anything else most people would
think has lost a logical way to go about
things we didn't view comedy at clubs
yeah never never been to one not only
didn't perform it had never been to one
there's like a famous One
Charlie Goodnights in Raleigh which I
think is gone now but yeah but we didn't
yeah we didn't do any it ever never
crossed our minds that we would do that
or we would be like well let's put on
like let's put on a little show or let's
go and
perform in this context
because it was very much about live
performance because it was like we're
gonna have this these students attention
uh but it's just it's funny because we
were yeah we were doing these things
that were that feel very like you gotta
like get your stuff together we're
always responsible and hindable to a
thought yeah I think I would still
categorize Us in that way uh you know
like we we carry out our lives and our
business
in our relationships in a very
responsible and dependable way almost
sometimes so much that that it can get
in the way of just like the being a
weird creative person we never did
anything because we felt like it we
always did something because we had
obligated ourselves to do it and then
it's like well that just means we like
we have to do it it doesn't matter what
you feel about it right okay well this
is good this is the way that you have to
do this if you're going to have this
apartment and you got to get these guys
to do this and you got to do the repairs
and then you got to get this job and you
have to do it in this way and do this
presentation in this way
we were all thinking that same way and
then when the opportunity to apply that
principle to entertainment came along in
a very weird way that it came along for
us we applied the same level of
process to it that has we've just kind
of carried over for the past 17 18 years
to up to this point it's um
but we've thankfully been able to do it
in a way that now yes
we are different people in a lot of ways
right in terms of like what is your day
like and what are you thinking about how
are you approaching things yes there's
still this like sense of responsibility
and Duty
to our family and our you know employees
and making sure that these things are
done in the right way still very
important to us it's like ingrained
you're never going to get rid of it
but yeah it's like if you if if that
version of me in that version of you
were to come into this room right now
and sit down
uh first of all I would be like hey man
I have a few a few style tips
yeah but I would also be like it's going
to be interesting to see uh the way that
that evolves over the next 20 years for
you as you start to think about it a
little bit more right
uh but then and then of course we would
have a really interesting spiritual
conversation
because we were very locked down on a
very particular way of thinking about
things and we're 100 sure without doubt
that we were right about it
um and so that would have been an
interesting conversation to see what we
have become the Heretics
um that we have become but
I think that if we were to have a
conversation about the creative things
that we're doing
if we were to be like let me tell you
what we did yesterday oh God we'd flip
out yeah oh yes we get to do that
because we never do that we never give
ourselves full permission to just like
just put the dream out there it was like
we didn't talk about the dream all the
time we talked about the thing that we
were working on the next thing and it
wasn't like if you have a band and
you're like you talk about the dream of
getting a record deal you know there's a
path like because there was no set path
it was like okay this may be all we've
got we've got this show at the end of
the year that well we're emceeing this
conference we're just going to turn it
into our show when we get our 10-minute
segments and then your brother's like
hey come to Carolina and talk to my
students and make it into a comedy show
it was like
okay we can obsess about that but it
wasn't
there were no we couldn't connect those
dots to any larger dreams so
it was very much like scrambling around
in the dark
and it was unspoken a lot of times you
know
um what it is we were working towards
because it you know it didn't exist
so you know I give us a lot of credit
that with no path with no
um instruction manual
we still found a way to like stick with
it to get we're going to get together we
have these we have these isolated events
and we're going to obsess about them
and that was fun and fulfilling and I
hope it can be encouraging for for
people you know because again
it doesn't have to be the case like you
know if you're if you're if you've got a
job right now you're working doing
something
um first of all make the most of what it
is that you're doing if I find as much
joy as you can in it you know uh but
maybe there's something meet a Nigerian
but maybe there's get married there's
something that is
um a point of passion that you don't
necessarily understand how that could
even be a career and maybe it isn't
maybe it's just a really awesome hobby
yeah but I just think it's important to
see that thing like a little plant
yeah and that plant needs things
that plant doesn't need to be put into
the attic and covered because it will
die give it a little something and
you'll have to find a new seed somewhere
right uh give it a little something all
along if you just keep giving it you
keep feeding it in some way
you don't know what it'll grow into yep
you know you have no idea but you got to
keep feeding it you know you know if you
don't kill it it can grow into something
on a motivational speech I like that
that involved a plant yeah
your wife would be proud yes she would
she would I think she's nurturing her
love for plants for that exact reason
um well that leads nicely into my wreck
if you're ready for that I'm ready for
this wreck yeah uh I hinted at this
recently when I said I had a wreck but I
didn't I took I told you like a
something from this wreck but now I'm
going to give you the wreck speaking of
creativity so
um I have found this podcast called
spark and fire fuel your creativity this
is from the wait what people in BBC
and
every single episode is essentially
talking to a creative person who did
something
that you probably know about for
instance a good episode is Ryan Johnson
talking about knives out and the name of
this episode is cultivate a child's
sense of wonder Knives Out director Ryan
Johnson so there's always like this is
kind of the principle of creativity that
we're going to suss out over the course
of
45 minutes or so and
it's an interview but what you hear is
like a setup it's very well organized in
this way that like
this is the principle that Ryan Johnson
is about to
elucidate in this
conversation about knives out and it's
going to be fun you're going to learn
things like how long has he had this
idea how did it come about like what was
he thinking like what childhood
experiences and stuff led him to and
he's actually realizing some of this
like in the interview like oh I guess
this is from my Grandma's house or
whatever huh so you hear that and but
it's formatted they format it and then
like the woman who hosts it will
be like I'm going to now that he's
finished talking because it's all
produced you know say the principle that
you should take here and how long is an
episode well uh like 45 this one the
Ryan Johnson was 45 minutes uh some of
them are 36 some of them are it's
between 30 and 45.
and then every episode is originally
scored by someone okay which is
well if you're going to talk about
creativity you better be creative that's
overkill for a podcast but I definitely
appreciate it spark and fire I you know
any there's like Pat Oswald talking
about like
coming back with this special after his
wife's death and and then there's just
people that I didn't even know about
like the the thing I was telling you
about the take your don't take yourself
too seriously but take your work very
seriously that's from this guy Mark
Bradford who's a visual artist who
creates these incredible things uh these
tapestries where I have to tell you
about this because I want to go see him
I think he's got some in LACMA but
he takes like a medieval
tapestry okay
that
and he takes a picture of it you know
like he takes a picture of a medieval
tapestry or takes a picture that he
finds a picture of one
then he prints it out on this giant
sheet of paper or canvas or something so
it's like feet across
and then he starts putting stuff onto it
all these different materials it feels
like kind of like junk but putting it in
there
inspired by and basically kind of like
oh here's a horse here I'm gonna make
the horse out of this thing and then I'm
gonna make this guy out of this thing
and he builds it and he builds it and he
builds it and so he's actually creating
interpretive layers of an original work
of art over time
through different materials and then he
takes acid and he starts peeling back
some of the layers with acid and he sees
how it happens and sometimes it works
and sometimes it doesn't
and it's just this remarkable
it I was so inspired listening to it I'm
not doing a great job of articulating it
but the idea that he's starting with
this original thing that's this
inspirational palette and then building
these creative layers on it and then
trying to capture something that's a
multi-layered interpretation of this
original work of art
and because this is such an amazing
thing and he does it so amazingly he's
become this very in-demand visual artist
that's got his work everywhere and he's
just very inspiring to listen to talk
about you haven't even seen the art look
at you no but I want to know this guy
he's in La I want to know him oh you
want to be his friend I want to be his
friend he's also six eight oh so I like
you know I don't think a lot of tall
people reach tall temperatures tall
people tend to have uh the demeanor that
I that I can I can match with we like
making ourselves why is your face
turning red we like making ourselves
small and doing big things
I like tall people I'm tall shout out to
tall people
spark and fire all right there it is
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you think about all this please leave us
a voicemail
with how you're processing things 1-88
earpod one
yeah hey red link my name is Barry I'm a
long time fan especially the podcast
uh I just wanted to say that I'm Blown
Away by the deaking and medium-sized
whole video that you guys made on the
Rhett and Link uh main Channel
uh when y'all talked about uh moving
away from TV and embracing more digital
content I think this is like a perfect
example of that
I'm just really proud of how good that
video is and I wanted to give props to
everyone involved in making it
uh in my opinion it was a masterpiece
and I hope it's indicative of more of
future content
so thank you guys a lot that I mean I'm
just blown away it was awesome thank you
guys
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign